So, why is it a big deal that we can get
HTTP responses with Netcat and printf?
It's a big deal, because printf doesn't
know anything about the network.
And Netcat doesn't know anything
about forming HTTP requests.
All Netcat is doing is, connecting to
a port and sending a string over it.
To the web server, that string happens
to look like an HTTP request and so,
the server responds.
Now, NetCat is a lower level
tool than something like Curl or
web app a.p.i for that matter.
What we've done here is to separate
out two different layers of activity.
The text of the issue to p request and
the connect to a port transmit some
data and get some results part.
In everyday software, the http
layer is implemented by programs
such as web browsers and servers.
Whereas the lower layer, TCP is
implemented in the operating system.
The NC command is a thin
wrapper over TCP.
Now, there are several
different layer models for
talking about network protocols.
In this course, we'll be using
the IETF model, which looks like this.
The top layer is the application layer.
Protocol such as htp or
SSH are application protocols.
Concepts we see at this
layer are things like,
URL's, passwords, the head command,
server headers, web pages.
Things that make sense to
specific applications,
such as web browsers or SSH clans.
Application protocols are based on
protocols with a transport layer,
like TCP and UDP.
These provide things like port numbers.
Transport layer protocols
are based on the internet layer,
which is basically the same as
the one single protocol IP.
It's at this layer,
that we start talking about things
like IP addresses and routes.
And IP in turn, runs on top of different
kinds of hardware, like wi-fi or
ethernet or DSL lines.
Layers above this,
don't need to worry about things like,
how strong is my wireless signal.
Each of these layers depends
on the one below it and
provides particular guarantees
to the layers above it.
You can think of them as offering and
using api's,
separating out specific concerns and
making it possible to reuse features.
Like both http and
ssh have some of the same needs.
They need the idea of making
a connection to a server and
those needs are bundled
into the TCP layer.
Now this layer model isn't perfect,
there are a bunch of network protocols
that don't exactly fit
into any of these layers.
But even with these
added to the picture,
you can notice that all of these
things above depend on IP.
An IP can depend on various
things underneath it.
IP itself,
is the only thing on its layer.
Some folks refer to this is the narrow
waste of the internet protocol stack,
because everything above and
below, goes through IP